today I would like to talk to you what
you can or should do when you turn that
contains misclassified labels who knows
Itoh get values and some technology
scientific literature as label noise I
decided to talk specifically about the
subject since I truly believe it is an
impact on various fields and
applications and machine learning and
e-learning work I hope that the end of
this short topic at least thank you will
find the ideas presented the useful for
your everyday machine learning research
just to make sure that everyone
understands I want to stress the
difference between two types of noises
common machine learning attribute noise
and labour noise in attribute knives it
means one or more attributes and the
training that I have wrong missing or
incomplete values this male character
deliberate altering due to measurement
errors or data corruption like the
example you see on screen in which the
original images were added Gaussian
noise in order to model possible
blurring of the original image in
general if the probability of attribute
noise is neglected this might cause the
model prediction to become less accurate
but now think of a different situation
and which not that attribute but the
original labour given to the instance is
wrong this is known as label noise in
general when comparing the two
researchers are shown with labour noise
is much more harmful and as such this
important understand how to handle it
and machine learning models of pipelines
researchers have shown that labor laws
can deteriorate to overall performance
of machine learning models this occurs
since labor laws alters at least to some
extent the relationship between the
measured output and the features one
example for ADC on screen in which we
tested an accuracy of 3 different
classifiers a random forest an SVM will
all be half Cornell EMS removal in ear
canal
as a function of percent of leap noise
in the training data although overall
show it is front panel all of them show
degradation in the performance as the
level of labour nodes in a plane that I
increases if you're a bit puzzled why
they have a different pattern don't
worry you will get the answer by the end
of this talk unfortunately this is not
the only downside of labour noise
researchers have found additional down
science such as a difficulty performing
feature selection a substantial increase
in the complexity of learn models and
the need to increase the training data
in order to produce the same test
accuracy like the example you see on
screen where the researchers needed many
more clean training instances in order
to reach a 90% accuracy threshold in
case the data was very noisy in
comparison to the noise free baseline in
general labour noise can occur due to
several reasons first of all expert
laborers do make mistakes from time to
time
the second is categorization of certain
instances maybe subjecting or very
confusing like I think the people in the
back having a bit of a hard time out
differentiating between this what was in
the muffins and that the corruption can
occur due to encoding problem so two
typing errors and forth which is really
relevant to current day machine learning
since labeling is a tedious thing to do
we often search for cheaper alternatives
such as crowdsourcing or image
annotation obtained directly from the
web and I think you will grieve me with
such data sources might produce labeling
of lower quality if the blinkin
statistical properties of labour noise
we can use the same terminology as in
missing values and such you can divide
labor noise into three categories
is noisy completely random and which
there's a probability P which is
independent but on the feature space and
on the original true label but the
observed label is different from the
true label the second is noisy trend on
where the Labour noise depends solely on
the true labor but it's still
independent of the feature space this
might occur if the instances of certain
classes are more prone to being
specified this allows us to define and a
symmetric labour noise and by so we can
define a transition matrix in which the
IJ component that picks the probability
of obtaining a class I when in fact the
true path was passed J the third type is
noisy not a random when the leben eines
depends both on the feature space and on
the original label this allows us to
model cases in which labor noise is more
frequent in cassette we can push our
boundaries Oh more frequent in
low-density regions in the feature space
in the same way between examining
classification we can also examine
regression post in general most of the
time we assume that the error is
additive and follows a zero mean
Gaussian distribution but in the same
way with a different classification we
can also define other categories such as
noisy at random where the error depends
only on the target value or noise in our
random where error depends both on the
target value and on the features I guess
you understand by now that the mission
of labor noise research is to find
algorithms which can help reduce the
negative effect of labour noise to do so
researchers need to find ways to make
machine learning models and pipelines
more robust to different types of labour
noise in general all the scientific
literature the big stream efforts are
free approaches how to handle labor
noise a cleansing approach a robust
model approach and the noise tolerant
learning approach
in the next few slides ago they briefly
describe each of these approaches and
give you examples how they are used in
machine learning pipelines the first is
the cleansing approach it is based on
detecting instances which are suspected
of labor noise once this instances are
suspected detected
you can either filter them out reweighed
them or real able them based on the
labor the model thinks is right the
detection of these instances can be done
using scoring methods which are also
used in anomaly detection or in outer
detection like you see the simple
example on screen were used a nearest
neighbor approach in which we filter out
instances that the class instance does
not agree with the majority class of
instances near it in the feature space
unfortunately this method are sometimes
unable to differentiate between his
label instances or hard to classify
instances and furthermore we tend to
filter out instances for minority
classes which will make the
classification even harder than it was
before the second is there a bus smother
approach it is based on methods which
are inherently more robust to labor
noise in this situation even if the man
the model is never filled about no
modeled this model still show high
tolerance were trained upon in upon
learning cells contaminated by cognitive
alley noise in general this approach is
divided into three methods the first
method examines different ML
architectures and models robustness to
label noise like the example you see on
screen in which two researchers have
examined three different neural network
architectures robustness to labor noise
the second model focuses on the
robustness of different the last
functions a robustness to labor noise in
the context of empirical risk
in this example you see when researchers
of examined to loss functions a median
absolute error in a categorical cross
entropy which were used as loss
functions for a multi-core certification
task than using a convolutional neural
network and a specific example the
researcher is shown with median absolute
error is more tolerant to label noise
the third is the noise tyrant learning
approach it is based on models that lend
the model weights and the noise
distribution parameters simultaneously
while assuming a certain prior regarding
the length of noise in this specific
example we talk about models which can
learn the knife's parameters
simultaneously the model for others like
an example using a basin approach and
you Chuo assume a certain crime a
different approach is to use a
parametric approach if you can assume
but the latent structure of the features
is indicative or the true label you can
use both the features and the noisy
labels in order to model the cruel Amos
and myself you use a semi supervised
approach to hunt the label noise in the
data
I ended one example of a machine
learning pipeline which incorporates a
model prediction and the noise
distribution parameters Lam similar
tenuously and this example in a bit of
handle presence over label noise in the
data the researchers of added a noise
layer which is the final layer of the
neural network which depicts the
contamination process if we can assume
that the noise follows in noisy at
random situation this layer will be
linear by nature that is the class size
by concise metrics depicting the
transition
- in true labels - noisy ones during the
training the model will learn both the
prediction model weights and then noise
weights and after the training we can
obtain the true labels by the output of
the lerp prior to the noise learn in the
rest of this talk I'm going to showcase
two practical examples of using noise
handling methodologies in a regression
task and classification puzzles this
example will show you that incorporating
such methodologies in the machine
learning pipeline help improve the
robustness to leave on noise these
methods are based on two of the three
approaches described earlier in the
stock the first one will be a cost
efficient one
it is based on a random noise which was
used to contaminate the well known
m-miss database the contamination
process in this example was done solely
on the training data while leaving the
test data noise free just to make sure
that everyone remembers and missed is a
database of grayscale images of the
handwritten digits ranging from zero to
none in order to solve this mordicus
application problem
I used the well-known net Network it
consists of two blocks where each bar
consists of a convolution honor and a
maximum error the second next pellagra
as well until fully connected layer in
order to handle the presence of label
noise in this data I decided to use a
relabeling approach and as you remember
relabeling is one of several methods
used to clean the training error from
suspected noise contaminated instances
very labeling is based on an approach
suggested by you just over a year ago it
is based in the assumption with the
label over the neural network can
replace labels which are suspected of
noise contamination it is based on the
assumption where is the training
progresses the model becomes more and
more accurate and the model prediction
can replace the original labels given
the instance it is also based on
assumption when your networks can
quickly learn a reasonable prediction
model before completely fitting to the
noisy labels house derelict Linda in
each epoch the model selects for each
instance a label or as the max active in
neuron but is their mother prediction
based on the prediction from the
previous Abba / original label the model
gives an opportunity for the neural
network to update each label for each
instance in every network and by so
hopefully to correct noisy labels in the
data the selection which one was serve
as label is based on a Bernoulli
distribution with an increasing
probability as the training progresses
of selecting the marks active learner
whereas the model prediction is label
over the original label to achieve this
effect the probability of the Bernoulli
distribution was selected to follow a
decaying exponential function as the
number of epochs in beginning of the
training as such a steep T decreases the
probability of selecting the max
activate a neuron increases where FC T
equals one we only choose the original
labels as labels and at C T equals zero
we only select the max activated neurons
as labels in the next two slides I'm
going to show you the results of this
experiment
first of all interested to know what
will happen if I change the labels of
40% of the instances from the training
data or the corruption again is that
only on a trainer not on the tester as
you can see when that a corruption
caused the test accuracy to decrease to
just under 60% however you also see
within the beginning of the process the
mall quickly
a reasonable prediction model and as
such after approximately 20 books but
that's the key Ricci reached a maximum
of about 92 percent and also the
training accuracy remained relatively
low since the trade data consists of
only 60 percent of the instances which
were not contaminated by labor noise
afterwards I reread the optimization
process but now with the relay billing
method as you can see adding their
labeling increase the pass that you
received from 57 percent up to 93
percent meaning la modem become much
more robust to label noise as occur
since as defending progresses the model
predictions replaced who originally was
given to the instance as you remember
the mother predictions were accurate in
predicting the non-contaminated
instances the next example will be a
regression one it is based on a project
I did 7 months ago while working a
cinema the project goal was to estimate
the monthly active usage of android
application where is the number of user
the percent of users reduced the
application at the least once during the
month
this project was charging due to several
reasons one of them is with our linear
set consist of target value noise in
order to handle with since ember I
decided to use an assemble regression
model in which the initial estimations
and based on different regressors will
estimate the monthly active usage from
my data the estimation of vis regressors
say the speeches will in sum the method
of combining all the estimations into
one predictive model in order to handle
the presence of target value noise in
the Veda I decided to use methodologies
from two approaches loss function which
is suited for target value noise
filtering method the last function is
based on their breaths regression method
called
an estimation and estimators are abandon
regressive which are inherently more
robust to target by ANOVA so too high
residuals when the context of target via
noise high residuals are quite
indicative of instances contaminated by
target value noise the trick as you
might call it which makes this robust
regresses more robust to target value
noise as betray replace the squared
error loss with the treatment loss
function which practically diminishes
the effect of instances of high
residuals you can understand how we work
using this simple example and which you
see the last functions of three
different regressors two are robust
regressors sugar to keep compared to the
window and least square regression as
you see the loss function increases less
rapidly as a function of the residual in
comparison to the last function of their
least square aggressor and as such the
memorization process will be less
affected by instances of high residuals
meaning the training would be more
tolerant to in assesses possibly
contaminated by target value noise the
filtering method is based on an anomaly
criterion seated for a regression test
the anomaly criterion based on two
factors the first is the ratio between
the target value and initial estimation
of each instance were again very high
ratios and very low ratios are quite
indicative of target value notice the
second is the target value itself were
instances of higher target values have a
bigger impact on estimation the
criterion space and taking the logarithm
of each other's factors multiplied the
two of them and taking the absolute
value the filtering method itself is
quite simple first of all we use an
initial estimation for each instance
then we can compute the normal criteria
and filter
out the top P percent of instances
according to their school then we
retrain the model but without those
instances and then we can campaign and
kept the final regression model however
you need to remember that the filtering
is done only to a training data since
there is no way to be absolutely sure
which instances are in fact contaminated
by target value noise here you see
results of this experiment in this
experiment I used three different loss
functions which is Bluebird in two key
which are robust regressive and the
squared error in which every loss
function was used once without the
filtering method and once without the
filter method you see the mean absolute
relative error scores on the left side
of the screen first of all what you see
is the a chance of loss function plays a
major role in improving the estimation
quality where robust regressors
outperform regular least square error
and second you see with the filter
method further improves the estimation
quality where it is a bigger impact on
the squared error in a small butts
appositive impact on the robust
progresses you need a course to remember
this is only one example it may be an
other example the filtering method might
play a much bigger role in improving the
estimation quality afterwards I examined
the effect of changing the threshold for
the filtering method in this specific
example the best resort what was
obtained while choosing threshold to be
0.25 meaning the best result was
obtained with filtering 25% of the
instances from the training error you
need to look at this is an equivalent
process to hyper parameter tuning than
in other supervised machine
tasks that's pretty much all I wanted to
talk to you about today I want to leave
you with three take-home messages first
labor noise can do harm for your model
if neglected or not treated the second I
described many techniques are many
methods how to handle labor mice what I
think you should do is go home try
different approaches the one with sushi
the specific application you're working
with and see if it helps make your model
more robust to labor noise and the third
there are still a love abundance of
questions remaining in this field and
it's interesting at least for me to try
to tackle this kind of problems and find
innovative solutions to them thank you
very very much for listening and if you
have now any questions that will be more
than glad to answer them okay that's the
that's the problem of the first approach
there is no way to be absolutely sure
and in this second example you saw I
told you I split it out on the instances
from a train and I left always this as
an impasse later in a general case yes
when you use the filtering method it
might filter out instances which are the
fact true hard to classify it happens
with no absolutely there's no guarantee
that you filter are instances that were
actually contaminated by nose and just
not very hard though your features are
not good enough to differentiate them
between other classes any other
questions for the first problem that I
know it's the tendency actually was
accuracy yeah it doesn't really give the
full picture because we don't know what
happens in terms of quality shorten so
I'm wondering that's also something that
one was it was a specific lives was the
accuracy are accurate in you
that asked that lesson and this example
you saw that I didn't I didn't change
the labels of the page data it was a
simulated example in a real date thing
you don't know but when you think about
label noise you think about the end
product where an actual person sees that
thing you don't want to get telling this
is five and it's actually mr. seven yes
[Music]
okay nearly from Byron Orlok yeah
regarded in your distribution yes you
can think of defining the distribution
of the dailies if it's coiled into some
features etc like if you do it in
regression task you say it's a Bernoulli
distribution or binomial distribution
whatever depends on the specific
question you're asking but the the
example is because you are understood to
solve this problem sometimes it is all
within analytical way so you need the
distribution to know to solve it other
approaches you can use you say I said do
you assume that the features are
indicated by the trip this is also a
private information you assume that they
are actually negative of a true class
this is answer question if you have any
others we can explain in more detail of
course
okay so again thank you and these are a
list of references if you are interested
there are many moments then a lot of
research in this field especially in the
last couple of years all the references
and if you rightly the noise you will
see let's say hundred of papers in this
field especially in the last couple
distance deep learning became so common
it may lie but no it's become even more
common
so again thank you
[Applause]